εύονται τα όρια του οργάνο όπόυ τι οποίο προερχονται δε σεύονται τους κανόνες ότι δεν
μπορούν να αναπτίσονται ανεξέλεκτα και τρίτων δημαιουργούν μεταστάσεις δηλαδή μεταφέρονται σε άλλα όργανα και δημειουργού
ναποικείες εκεί που δεν έχουν από την αρχική τους μορφή καμία να πολίτος σχέση γι
αυτό λέγονται διατερούν γι αυτό αναφερόμαστε και λέμε κακοήθειες είναι τα ύτρα τα οποία δεν
σθεονται τους κανόνες του οργανισμόύ μας που σεύονται όλα τα υπολυπακύτρα πολλές φορές λέμε κάνε
καλύ διατροφή κάνε καλή ζωή για να μηνεις μακριά πα αυτά και μέένα μου έτυχε
να γνωρίζω πρόσωπο το οποίο ήταν στην κυμναστική γινή διατροφή μακριά από ότι δήποτεον μπορούσε
να τοδημιουργήσει και τελικά διαγνώστηκε μεκαρκίνο είναι ένας μήθος λά αυτά ρόχι δεν είναι μήθως
ότι χρειάζεται η γινή διατροφή η γινι ζωή αναφισβήτητα αλλά δεν είναι μόνον αυτόν το
οποίο δημειοργή τις κακοήθειες ι για να δηιοργηθεί μια κακοήθεία σημαίνει ότι το ανασωπιτικώ μα
σύστημα κάπου απαιτυχε είτε γιατί δεν είχε πρόσβαση στο σημείο που πηρχενικάκοήθεια για να την
αναγνωρήσει να την καταπολεμήσει ή δεν την αναγνώρισ το κύτ ως καοηθες και με αυτό
τον τρόπον το άφησε να εξελύσεται τώρα γιατί απέτυχε το ανοσωπιτικό μας σύστημα υπάρχουν